hey everybody its Mike Balto's from
order flows and I'm pleased to announce
that on Thursday January 25th at 4:15
Eastern time I'll be doing a
presentation with ninja trader on order
flowing explain the advantages of order
flow and if you are interested in order
file you should attend because if you
attend you'll get a copy of my 150 page
book trading an order flow now it's not
an actual physical book copy you'd have
to download it and you could print it up
or you could just you know read it on
your phone or read it on your tablet
however you like but you know why is
this this why am i doing this
presentation is because you know I want
to teach traders how to use order flow
so if you're ever you find yourself
struggling to get an edge over other
traders you know I like this picture
three-cheese versus for cheese you know
both made by craft no sometimes my wife
says hey you know I'm making lasagna go
buy some cheese well know what type you
want on all three cheese well a you know
maybe if you use four cheese it might
taste better you know it's kind of a
silly silly analogy but it's one I like
to keep things light hearted and put
things in context but again you know
it's on Thursday January 25th at 4:15
Eastern time and it's it's sponsored by
a ninja trader a ninja trader honestly
is is coming out with I had their own
order flow tool I think that's one of
the reasons why they want to get a lot
of order flow webinars out there in the
meantime but you know it's you know I
really want to teach you how to use
order flow and you know whether you use
my software or whether you use another
software or you know another vendors
version of order flow you know I really
just want you to understand how to use
order flow but again you know the
presentation I'm going to be doing is
for educational and informational
purposes only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make it any type of
investment decision you know futures
training is risky contain substantial
risk and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all are
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or life still only risk capital
should be used for trading and past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results and you
know you're not buying bitcoins so you
know I mean commodities and futures you
know can go up and down there's what
they call circuit breakers you know with
with the Bitcoin there's no circuit
breakers in the actual Bitcoin market on
the futures there are but you know
bitcoin is just one of those it's just
another form of investment and you know
just as futures are so
well be talking about is the immediate
benefits of introducing order flow into
your training and you know a lot of
traders don't understand the benefits of
using order flow and I'm going to
explain that in the presentation another
thing I would talk about is I'm going to
show you the easiest way to understand
what's happening in the market so you
can make better trading decisions using
order flow you know sometimes you know
people look at an order flow chart and
they're very confused because they don't
understand what it is that they're
really looking at and once they do
really the market becomes a lot easier
to solve you know if you think of the
market as puzzle once you understand you
know what were the end pieces are the
edge pieces are on the puzzle you know
that's that's your starting point and
hopefully after the presentation you
will understand but another thing I want
to understand understand is why order
flow matters now some people say order
flow is garbage order flow is rubbish it
doesn't matter you know I can trade
price action and make good decisions
again you know if you're successful in
your trading and you don't want to take
your trading further okay fine you know
maybe order flow is not going to be for
you but you know if you're somebody that
wants to improve their game you know you
will want to understand order flow again
you know the great basketball player is
Michael Jordan every year he would find
a new facet to him improve his game you
know when he started out as all slam
dunks you know then over the years he
had a defense he became Defensive Player
of the Year how many years in a row so
you know it's not about just saying okay
I have a way to make money or I have a
way to be successful in the markets and
that's it and never evolve no you should
always be constantly evolving whether
it's in trading or whether it's in your
job or whether it's in your relationship
always look for ways to improve yourself
now getting on one of the things that
really bothers me is people say well to
be successful in anything he takes
10,000 hours you did people understand
with 10,000 hours is imagine you're
working eight hours a day
do the math eight hours a day five days
a week for 52 weeks that's four and a
half years or four point eight years
that's almost five years you know that's
not including weekends or holidays
now I have never met a company a trading
firm specifically that's gonna hire you
and say okay just in
screen for $10,000 no you know if if you
can't figure it out relatively quick
you're not gonna have a job much longer
they're not gonna fund you for five
years until you quote figure it out to
become an expert at it you know when I
left the trading floor and I worked
upstairs this is what Dean Witter and
you know this is when Globex was just
you're starting to take off this was in
the 90s early 90s it was unemployment
week and I started on Sunday night and I
don't even know how to really even use
the Globex terminal you know I had done
a you know a couple order entries here
and there but that was about it and you
know so it was a brand new way of
trading to me and I just remember the
one of the guys on the desk says okay
it's it today's Monday you got until
Friday to figure it out you know and
because Friday was the non-farm payrolls
biggest you know it's still a big number
but you know back in the 90s that was
quote the number that everyone looked
for every month and volatility in the
espys was you know was that was off the
charts you know you'd have you know even
in the bonds you get a full point up a
full point down now you know it reacts a
little bit but you know if you can have
a mistake and it's gonna be against you
guys it's gonna be very expensive so you
know forget about this eight hours a day
five days a week over fifty two weeks
you know is equaling 5 years for 10,000
hours no I really want to teach you how
to get up to speed on order full click
quickly you know I like to teach people
order flow and really I say you know if
you just do what I say I'll say to what
I say but you know if you just follow
the steps that I lay out for you you can
pick it up have a good working knowledge
add it to your training within two weeks
that's not $10,000 that's two weeks not
4.8 years that's two weeks and that's
you know even if you're just using one
or two hours a day at least you'll get a
good understanding and can start using
it now if you want to speed it up you
know you could do it in two or three
days you know again I'm talking from
somebody that's got no experience with
it
to getting to a level where you can
start understanding
order flow and another thing I'll talk
about is spot price rejection and use it
to your advantage again you know people
don't understand why markets my move
stop right because you see price
rejection you know people say well
you've hit resistance well sometimes you
hit price rejection - you know markets
reject prices as either being too high
or too low and you know another thing
that I'll be talking about is market
generated support and resistance levels
you know a lot of people think they
understand support and resistance but
they really don't you know they're
they're just basically looking at a
chart and saying well you know price
traded here that that's got to be a
support level or a resistance level we
traded here twice well not really you
know it can be something else that's
going on and I'm going to show you you
know with the order flow if you watch
some of my other videos you'll
understand how the market can tip you
off that there is support or resistance
as soon as you trade a level right and
and that's where your edge is going to
come in because you'll know if you're
using order flow that you've hit a level
where there's support or there's
resistance right as soon as you hit it
okay and you start to move away you'll
know then that you have support or
resistance and I'm gonna give you away
I'm gonna give you one of my trade stops
this is a trade setup that I've been
talking about to my users for how many
years already it's it's a great setup
you could risk three ticks per trade
with potentials for 10 to 15 ticks per
trade level everyone always says so you
got to have what your risk reward or
what's your winning percentage you know
if you've got a trade where you're only
risking three ticks to get back you know
ten or fifteen ticks the odds are on
your side okay so that's that's really
what what you should be looking for as a
trader and again pain relief just ahead
you know I'm gonna make order flow easy
join me on the 25th at 4:15 Eastern Time
the signup is in the link below you can
also just type in order flows comm slash
webinar I'll take you to the landing
page then you can just click on there
and go to the actual page I try to keep
things simple people say well why is you
know the order flow sign up or to close
com sign up page a little bit different
than the link in the description is
because one is
is you know just goes to my websites
from my website and I just forward you
or it takes you to sign up page on
ninjatrader so again you know if you
can't attend it's good to at least
register because at least you know
you'll be on the distribution list for
future webinars on order flow and you
know if you haven't subscribed to my
channel please do and you know want to
learn more about order flow visit my
website order close calm and I hope to
see you there on on Thursday bye bye